The most effective thing you
can do to havemore fun
is to focus on
its ingredients,
by which I mean, do everything
you can to fillyour life
with more moments of playfulness,
connection and flow.
So by playfulness, I just mean
having a lighthearted attitude.
When we have fun,
our guard is down,
and we're not taking
ourselvestoo seriously.
Connection refers to the feeling of
having a special, shared experience.
And thenflow is the state
where we are so engaged
and focused on
whatever we're doing
that we caneven
lose track of time.
So to start with, reduce distractions
in order to increase flow.
Anything that distracts you is
going to kick you out of flow
and prevent you
from having fun.
My second suggestion, is
to increase connection
by interacting more with other
human beings inreal life.
You might be amazed
by how good
just one little moment of
connection can make youfeel.
And if you do find
someone to connect with,
maybe ask them to join you in
trying mythird suggestion,
which is to increase
playfulness
by finding opportunities to rebel.
I'm talking about
finding ways to
break the rules of
responsible adulthood,
and giving yourselfpermission to
get a kick out of your own life.